hey guys dr. Berg here in this video we're going
to talk about how to relieve SI joint pain what
does si stand for sacroiliac joint okay so now
you have the pelvis right here right and then
we have two little joints right there so if we
look at the back part we got this thing called
the sacrum which is the foundation of your pelvis
and then we have these two little bones right here
that are called ilions okay so we have sacroiliac
joints so they move right back here you got two of
them and that's where they're located okay so what
I want to talk about I want to talk about there's
three different causes of sacroiliac joint pain
the most common one which I'm going to give you
a demo is referred pain so the pain in this
little joint could be referred from if it's
in a female body the ovary the ovary if there's
a cyst there if there's a problem there it will
refer pain exactly right behind to the back part
okay and if that's the case I'm going to show you
a really simple little test to see if that is the
problem and if it turns off the pain then we know
there could be a problem there and you just need
to add a little seek help seek help has iodine
iodine reduces estrogen it helps with cysts on
the ovaries and that usually resolves it pretty
nicely okay so so if it's referred pain it's not
coming from the you know you never hurt your back
the whole thing and especially if it happens
that time of the month we know it's going to be
the ovary I've had a lady come in the office and
her ovary it was blowing out the SI joint that is
causing the joint to misalign so I sent her to
the doctor for an ultrasound the ovary was the
size of a lemon it should be the size of an almond
okay it's swole up and that pushed pressure all
the way back there and throughout her her back
on that side so we gave her some seek help and
the thing started shrinking more and more and more
over time and all the pain went away now in a male
body they don't have ovaries okay so but they do
have these little tubes that come down from the
kidney and they're called the ureters they're just
basically tubes from the kidney to the bladder and
a lot of times they might have a little bit
of a stone or a little calcium deposit or a
uric acid crystal right into that little tube
where it connects to the bladder so if that's
the case I'm gonna show you how to test for that
ovary is located right here okay so you have the
hip right here it's lower so what you want to do
since let's say that pretend the pain is on her
right SI joint she's gonna press into the over
in the same side so just take your your fingers
and just kind of press and massage gently into
that over it okay just gonna do that for maybe
15 seconds now what's gonna happen either the
pain in her back is gonna go away or it's not
okay okay relax if the pain goes away then we know
there's a connection between this and her back and
if that's the case we're gonna recommend seek
help okay I have my own version with the from
Iceland it's organic because it's real pure or
you can just find another one that's equivalent
but the estrogen needs to come down to help any
cysts or anything going on in your bruise so if
it was on this ovary you would do the opposite
side on that on this side here so you do this
side right here okay so that's how you would
do it if it's referred now in a male body let's
pretend that you're a guy what's gonna happen
you would press the same spot and what that is
the kidneys right here and it connects with the
tube down into the bladder there's going to be
a little point right there were a lot of times
a uric acid crystal or a stone might just sit
right there and irritate and refer back to the
SI joint so again you press right there if the
pain goes away then we know there could be some
junk there that you need to take some potassium
citrate that's what you need to get and you can
get it as a supplement anywhere it's really simple
it's really inexpensive you take it and that
will be great for dissolving any stones that
you might have because one of the things that
if you're on the ketogenic diet you may start
more susceptible to kidney stones but potassium
citrate is the antidote and it's really good to
take especially since potassium you lose your
potassium when you go on a ketogenic diet so
especially if you don't eat enough vegetables
so that's what we want to retain there now if
you have the actual joint pain then I'm gonna
show you how to deal with that you're basically
gonna press you're gonna need someone's help but
you can actually do it if you have a tennis ball
let's say you hurt let's say the problem is not
being referred it's actually coming from the joint
because you sit because you know the sideways
or something like that and you just have some
inflammation there or an injury whatever then what
you do is if you hurt on the right side you lay on
your back on a tennis ball on the opposite side so
if she hurts on the right you could have someone
massage on the left and work that out and work
out the muscles that are connected to the SI joint
and that would be the glutes and these muscles up
here or you she could be laying on her back with a
tennis ball right here and putting pressure on the
opposite side okay so if the pains over here you
press on the opposite side if the pain is over
here you press on this side and that's the way
you get rid of pain in the SI joint and the last
technique is if you fell on your tailbone a long
time ago and you smack your tailbone and the force
travels up to the spine up in the back of the neck
what happens the whole spine becomes very rigid
from that point on and because there's a little
it's kind of like saran wrap it's called the
dura that's in an info spinal column that thing
gets tight and it can pull and keep one of the
sacroiliac joints tight or even the lower back
so it could come from that if that's the case I'm
going to show you how to correct that there's a
certain stretch on that so so let's go ahead and
do the demo right now so check this next part out
now if someone fell on their tailbone the force
hits the tailbone goes right up to the back of
the skull right here and so what you want to do
and you're going to need someone to do this on you
but to get rid of a tailbone injury we actually
work on the neck part okay so what you want to
do is you want to take the back of the neck and
I have my finger attached here and we're going to
stretch I'm lifting up on the back part and I'm
pushing down on my hand kind of like taking a
basketball and rotating it so we want to take the
finger gently underneath the skull lift up stretch
up and then flex it down okay making sure that
we're not pulling her hair and then we're gonna
stretch this about I do like seven times okay and
then I'll also do the other side with my thumb
it'll come and I'll lift it up this way and I'm
just lifting the skull up and stretching forward
and try not to mess up her hair which is the most
important thing okay and what you're going to do
is you're going to create the space that's going
to release the tension all the way down to the SI
joints and the back will feel like it's tingly
and warm and like the circulation it's a great
way to handle an old injury from the tailbone so
go ahead and apply this put your comments below